-James, can I get some thank-you
note-writing music, please?
♪♪
Looks good.
He looks good.
-Oh, my God.
-It's coming in hot!
[ Laughter ]
It's coming in hot!
♪♪
Thank you, going on a diet,
for being the original inflation
reduction act.
Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Topical.
-Diet season.
-Thank you, "House of the
Dragon," for sounding like
a Chinese food place
with two stars on Yelp.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, camouflage shorts,
for being perfect
if you don't want people seeing
your crotch in the forest.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh! Wow.
I can't see anything.
-Ankles and a torso.
It's amazing.
-Disappeared.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you,
meeting your college roommate,
for being a great way
to get to know the person
whose guts you'll hate
in three months.
[ Applause ]
Oh, this is a good one.
Thank you, state fairs,
for being 10% rides and 90%
"Can I deep-fry this object?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sure. Twinkie? Go for it.
[ Laughter ]
-Deep-fried butter.
That was a crazy one.
-Which one?
-Deep-fried butter.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah. You're going like,
"That's a joke, right?" No.
-Deep-fried butter is a jam,
yeah.
Have you ever had deep-fried
Oreo and all that stuff?
-Yeah.
-It's pretty good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't care what anybody says.
I think deep-fried food is good.
It tastes good.
-I don't care what anyone says.
Christmas is fun.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I don't care what anybody says.
-I don't care what anyone says.
-I like my birthday, you know
what I mean? I have fun.
-I like to celebrate it
every year.
-You know what, too?
I'm going out on a limb.
I mean, the Beatles are
pretty good.
[ Laughter ]
-That's you, man.
It's all on you. It's all you.
You be you, man.
-Yeah.
UB40.
-Yeah, man.
I be 47.
-Ooh, nice.
-My birthday was in September.
-Really?
-Yeah. It was interesting.
-What did you do
for your birthday?
-It was in September,
so it's like fall,
so it was autumnal theme.
-Right.
-So I said, well,
maybe Nancy and I will go on
like on a hay ride or something.
-Oh, my God, hay ride.
-So, I go, "Well, who's gonna
drive the tractor?"
She said, "Dude, we don't have
a tractor."
So I had to buy one
from a farmer.
I'm like, "Nice to meet you."
He's like, "My name's Hank."
I go, "Oh, that's an odd voice."
He goes, "I was just doing
a character. My name's Hank."
I go, "Oh, nice to meet you.
Could I borrow your tractor?"
He's like, "Borrow?
No, but you can buy one."
I go, "Alright, how much is it?"
He's like, "$300."
I go, "Thank you." So, $300.
I bought the tractor.
I hooked it up.
Then I go to get hay.
-Right. Where'd you get hay at?
-Well, then I went to --
I went to the, uh...
-Hay store?
-Yeah, the hay store, thank you.
They got all the hay,
put it in the back,
and as I was driving away, you
know what the owners said?
-What?
-"Hay!" Yeah.
So I go like, "Hay." It was fun.
[ Applause ]
You had to be there.
-Oh, yeah.
-You had to be there.
-Oh, I had to be there.
-No, it was a mandatory party.
Yeah.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, travel toothbrushes,
for saving me a whole two inches
of space in my suitcase.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Whoo. Wow.
Almost didn't make it
on the plane.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, pet birthday parties,
or as your dog remembers it,
the worst day of their life.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank-you notes.